Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Once more their captain stepped forward. We all know what lies ahead, he said. Let no man doubt that Jesus Christ, our Lord, is with us and will bring us through to victory. But we are few in number. We must not falter. We must not hope for aid.
感谢收听《历史的余味》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。他们的队长再次向前迈出一步。他说，我们都知道前方等待着什么。不要怀疑，耶稣基督，我们的主，与我们同在，并将带领我们走向胜利。但我们人数稀少。我们绝不能动摇。我们绝不能指望援助。
We can only trust in the Lord and in our own strength and courage. Cortes studied their faces, burned and blistered by the sun. In their eyes, he could see excitement, determination, uncertainty, dread. He knew exactly how they felt, but he dared not show a flicker of doubt. He raised his voice. Our fate lies in our own hands. So now let us go forward and conquer this land or die in the attempt. Let us conquer or die, up went the chant. Conquer or die, conquer or die, conquer or die. And as the cheers rose once more over the sands, Cortes looked for Malinche, and in her deep, dark eyes, he saw a gleam of triumph.
我们只能信靠主，信靠我们自己的力量和勇气。科尔特斯注视着他们的脸，那些被太阳灼伤和晒出水泡的脸。在他们的眼中，他能看到兴奋、决心、不安和恐惧。他完全明白他们的感受，但他不敢流露出一丝怀疑。他提高了嗓门。我们的命运掌握在自己手中。所以现在，让我们前进，征服这片土地，否则就在尝试中死去。让我们征服或死亡，口号声响起。征服或死亡，征服或死亡，征服或死亡。当欢呼声再次在沙滩上响起时，科尔特斯寻找着马林切，在她深邃、黑暗的眼睛里，他看到了一丝胜利的光芒。
So there, Dominic, in your new book, Fall of the Aztecs, part of your Adventures in Time series for children, you were pitching in, giving us your take on Malinche's role in Cortés' decision to march on the capital of the Mexica, Tenochtitlan. And this is a thrilling moment, isn't it? I'm all about giving female characters agency, Tom, as you know, in the rest of history generally. Yes, so this is the latest Adventures in Time, available from all good bookshops. And we talked last time about Hernan Cortez's world-shaping decision that instead of going
那么，多米尼克，在你的新书《阿兹特克人的陨落》中，作为你为儿童创作的《时间冒险》系列的一部分，你参与其中，向我们讲述了你对马林切在科尔特斯决定进军墨西加首都特诺奇蒂特兰一事中所起作用的看法。这是一个激动人心的时刻，不是吗？汤姆，你知道，我一直致力于在历史的余味中赋予女性角色自主权。是的，这是最新的《时间冒险》，在各大书店均有销售。我们上次谈到了埃尔南·科尔特斯那个改变世界的决定，即他没有在
back after his scouting expedition along the coast of Mexico, he will turn inland towards the capital of this people, the Mexica, as we would call them, the Aztecs. And I think it is absolutely plausible, Tom, that he has relied for advice on his interpreter, translator. Well, who else would he rely upon? I mean, he doesn't have anyone else. She may well now be his lover. She mean, he doesn't have anyone else. She may well now be his lover. She may, of course, be manipulating him. She may be a victim.
沿着墨西哥海岸进行侦察探险后返回，而是转向内陆，前往这个民族——我们称之为墨西加人，即阿兹特克人——的首都。汤姆，我认为他依靠他的口译员、翻译来获取建议是完全合理的。好吧，他还能依靠谁呢？我的意思是，他没有其他人了。她现在很可能已经是他的情人了。我的意思是，他没有其他人了。她现在很可能已经是他的情人了。当然，她也可能在操纵他。她也可能是一个受害者。
We cannot know. But I think there is an element of her having more agency than historians have long believed. So brilliant work on her by Camilla Townsend, a historian we talked about last time. She really plays up Malinche's agency. And that scene that you just described on the beach the beach cortez's speech so i'd kind of cobbled that together from a couple of different sources one of them from bernal diaz a contestador who is our best spanish source on all this of course a lot of what bernal diaz is saying may well be made up this is his memoir so this apparently there's a book-length study by the Mexican historian Juan Mirales examining the reliability or otherwise of Banal Diaz, which is titled Y Banal Mintio and Banal Lied. Yeah. We talked last time about how the Spanish, everything they say is political. So everything they say later about their conquest is designed to protect their own position and to indemnify themselves against prosecution so it has a political meaning but on top of that the spanish are using formulas from the chivalric
我们无法得知。但我认为，她拥有的自主权比历史学家长期以来认为的要多。卡米拉·汤森（Camilla Townsend）对她的研究非常出色，我们上次谈到过这位历史学家。她确实强调了马林切的自主权。你刚才描述的沙滩上的那个场景，科尔特斯的演讲，我是从几个不同的来源拼凑出来的，其中一个是来自贝尔纳·迪亚斯（Bernal Diaz），一位征服者，当然，他是我们关于这一切最好的西班牙语来源。贝尔纳·迪亚斯所说的大部分内容很可能是编造的，这是他的回忆录，所以显然有一本由墨西哥历史学家胡安·米拉莱斯（Juan Mirales）撰写的书长研究，专门审查贝尔纳·迪亚斯的可靠性，书名是《Y Banal Mintio》，意为“贝尔纳撒谎了”。是的。我们上次谈到西班牙人所说的一切都是政治性的。所以他们后来关于征服的一切言论都是为了保护自己的地位，并使自己免受起诉，所以它具有政治意义，但除此之外，西班牙人还使用了他们从小阅读的骑士
romances and the classical texts that they have grown up reading but also they may well not understand what's going on yeah you know they are strangers in a strange land kind of bewildered i will say one thing about bernal dia That speech on the beach, he says, Cortes then adduced many beautiful comparisons from history and mentioned several heroic deeds of the Romans. We answered him that we would follow his orders as the die had been cast and that we with Caesar, when he passed the Rubicon, had now no choice left. Besides which, everything we did was for the glory of God and his majesty, the emperor.
传奇和古典文本中的套路，但他们也可能根本不理解正在发生的事情。是的，你知道，他们是异乡的陌生人，有点不知所措。关于贝尔纳·迪亚斯，我要说一件事：关于沙滩上的那次演讲，他说，科尔特斯随后引用了许多历史上的优美比喻，并提到了罗马人的几项英雄事迹。我们回答他，我们会听从他的命令，因为木已成舟，就像凯撒渡过卢比孔河时一样，我们现在别无选择。此外，我们所做的一切都是为了上帝和他的陛下，皇帝的荣耀。
I mean, that's probably just as fictionalized as my own version that you read out. But they are conscious, you described them as cosplaying the Greeks and the Romans, that moment when they turn to go inland, they are conscious they're doing a Julius Caesar, Alexander the Great style. They're hoping that they will go down in history as Caesar and Alexander did before them. What is Cortes hoping for? What does he think is going to happen? He is marching on a city that he knows is fabulously large, fabulously beautiful, fabulously rich, teeming with armed warriors. What does he think he's going to achieve by marching on it? Tom, we don't know. This is the amazing thing. Does he even know himself? I think he thinks this is a hell of a lot better than being a notary in
我的意思是，这可能和你读出的我的版本一样，都是虚构的。但他们是有意识的，你形容他们是在扮演希腊人和罗马人，当他们转身向内陆进发的那一刻，他们意识到自己正在进行一场朱利叶斯·凯撒、亚历山大大帝式的行动。他们希望自己能像之前的凯撒和亚历山大一样载入史册。科尔特斯在期待什么？他认为会发生什么？他正向一座他知道规模宏大、美丽绝伦、极其富有且武装战士众多的城市进军。他认为通过进军这座城市能实现什么？汤姆，我们不知道。这就是令人惊奇的地方。他自己知道吗？我想他认为这比在
the middle of nowhere. Yeah. So this is where the chivalric stuff comes in. It's like an adventure from a knightly romance or indeed a Roman expedition. Tom, you might as well ask, what did Alexander hope for when he marched into India? What was the best that was going to happen? At some level, people behave in history, they just take a chance. Okay, but Alexander marching on India, I mean, he's conquered the entire Persian Empire. He knows that he's got the measure of pretty much everyone he's up against. Cortes has no idea what's waiting for him. No, I mean, that's what makes it even more extraordinary than Alexander, I think. That Cortes doesn't speak the language, he doesn't understand the customs,
荒郊野外当公证人要好得多。是的。所以这就是骑士文学发挥作用的地方。这就像骑士传奇或罗马远征中的一次冒险。汤姆，你还不如问，亚历山大进军印度时期待什么？最好的结果会是什么？在某种程度上，人们在历史中的行为，只是在冒险。好吧，但亚历山大进军印度，我的意思是，他已经征服了整个波斯帝国。他知道他有能力对付他所面对的几乎所有人。科尔特斯根本不知道等待他的是什么。不，我的意思是，我认为这使得它比亚历山大更非同寻常。科尔特斯不会说当地语言，他不了解习俗，
he doesn't understand the religion. He's unfamiliar with the flora and fauna, the food, everything. He has no concept of what awaits him. So it's kind of where courage fuses into lunacy, fuses into greed, fuses into confidence in Christ, the whole swirls of motives, perhaps. Exactly, exactly. He's also leading, Tom, this very bizarre, disparate band of people, several hundred Spanish conquistadors who are not soldiers,
他不了解宗教。他对植物、动物、食物，一切都感到陌生。他根本不知道等待他的是什么。所以这有点像是勇气与疯狂、贪婪、对基督的信心融合在一起，也许是各种动机的漩涡。正是如此，正是如此。汤姆，他还带领着这群非常古怪、各不相同的人，几百名西班牙征服者，他们不是士兵，
so it's not an army. They are stonemasons, blacksmiths. They are armed, but a lot of them have not really seen much combat, probably some combat killing Tainos on Hispaniola and Cuba, but those are massacres rather than battles. They have lots of porters, slaves, Taino slaves, some Totonacs who come with them to carry all their stuff, and off they go.
所以这不是一支军队。他们是石匠、铁匠。他们装备精良，但其中许多人并没有真正经历过太多战斗，可能在伊斯帕尼奥拉岛和古巴杀过一些泰诺人，但那些与其说是战斗，不如说是屠杀。他们有很多搬运工、奴隶、泰诺奴隶，还有一些托托纳克人随行搬运所有东西，然后他们就出发了。
And now, by the way, for listeners who are thinking this is a very long series, as we just said to Theo, our producer, we're actually massively condensing and crunching down the details of these incredibly complicated expeditions. But also, the pace of it is starting to pick up now. Yes. They go inland from the coast.
顺便说一下，对于那些认为这是一个非常长系列的听众，正如我们刚才对我们的制片人西奥所说，我们实际上是在极大地压缩和精简这些极其复杂的探险细节。但它的节奏现在也开始加快了。是的。他们从海岸向内陆进发。
They go up into the mountains. The temperature changes. It was initially incredibly hot and humid. It starts raining. It becomes quite cold. It becomes a real trudge. They get up there and it's really cold. And a lot of their Taino porters die.
他们进入山区。温度发生了变化。起初非常炎热潮湿。开始下雨了。变得相当冷。变成了一段真正的苦旅。他们到达那里时，天气非常冷。他们的许多泰诺搬运工死了。
Or they say they die. Having written this book, Tom, it's not so long since we did Alexander the Great. And I'd written an adventure in time about Alexander the Great. And I was struck by how much the Cortez mountain journey accounts resemble those of Alexander. So in other words, the conquistadors are following literary formulas when they tell these stories. So they talk about the Taino porters lay down and died. And I thought, God, that's so similar to all the people in Alexander the Great in Afghanistan. Anyway, their first big interesting meeting, they come down into a valley to a place
或者他们说是死了。汤姆，写完这本书后，距离我们做亚历山大大帝的节目没过多久。我写过一本关于亚历山大大帝的《时间冒险》。我惊讶地发现，科尔特斯的山地旅程记录与亚历山大的记录是多么相似。换句话说，征服者在讲述这些故事时遵循了文学套路。所以他们谈到泰诺搬运工躺下就死了。我想，天哪，这和亚历山大大帝在阿富汗时的人们太像了。无论如何，他们的第一次重大有趣的会面，他们下到一个山谷，到了一个
called Zautla. And the chief there is called O Olentetle. The Spaniards don't approve of Olentetle at all. They see him very much as a sort of Andrew Tate figure because he has 30 wives, which they regard with disapproval. I have to say there's an element of hypocrisy there, given some of their behavior. Proclivities and behavior, yeah. Yes. He agrees to let them sleep inside. He says, I'll put you all up. I mean, this massive band of people, several hundred people, this mob, basically. And Cortes takes them into the square and they see the places lined with human skulls. So he claims.
叫扎乌特拉（Zautla）的地方。那里的酋长叫奥伦特特尔（O Olentetle）。西班牙人一点也不赞同奥伦特特尔。他们非常把他看作是一个类似安德鲁·泰特（Andrew Tate）的人物，因为他有30个妻子，他们对此表示不赞同。我必须说，考虑到他们的一些行为，这其中有一种虚伪的成分。倾向和行为，是的。是的。他同意让他们睡在里面。他说，我会安置你们所有人。我的意思是，这群庞大的人，几百人，这群暴民，基本上。科尔特斯把他们带进广场，他们看到广场上排列着人头骨。他是这么声称的。
So spitted human skulls hanging from beams. Not implausible, we have to say. Totally plausible. Totally plausible because we know the Aztecs had skull racks. And this is not kind of Aztec heartland territory, but it's a place that would pay tribute to the Aztecs. Culturally adjacent. Culturally adjacent, exactly. Cortes is very shocked by this.
所以，被串起来的人头骨挂在横梁上。我们不得不说，这并非不可信。完全可信。完全可信，因为我们知道阿兹特克人有头骨架。而且这并不是阿兹特克人的核心领土，但这是一个会向阿兹特克人纳贡的地方。文化上邻近。文化上邻近，正是如此。科尔特斯对此感到非常震惊。
He must have heard the name Montezuma, or he must have heard about the emperor. Because he says to Olentetle, are you a vassal of Montezuma, my lord? And Olentetle apparently says to him, all men are vassals of Montezuma, for he rules all the world. And Cortes is like, okay, we're entering the empire. Right. And there is a reminder of the world perspective of the Mexica and the Nahuatl more generally, that for them, the idea that there is a world beyond the seas that bound Mexico is equally incomprehensible. It is. I mean, that's the fascination of it, isn't it? Although they must know that there are people who are not them because we know that they traded with Central Americans. Of course.
他一定听说过蒙特祖马这个名字，或者他一定听说过这位皇帝。因为他对奥伦特特尔说，你是蒙特祖马的附庸吗，我的领主？奥伦特特尔显然对他说，所有人都是蒙特祖马的附庸，因为他统治着整个世界。科尔特斯心想，好吧，我们要进入帝国了。没错。这提醒了我们墨西加人和纳瓦特尔人更广泛的世界观，对他们来说，存在着环绕墨西哥的海洋之外的世界这一想法同样是不可理解的。确实。我的意思是，这就是它的魅力所在，不是吗？尽管他们一定知道有不是他们的人，因为我们知道他们与中美洲人有贸易往来。当然。
But you're right. They never guessed there would be people on the other side of the sea. That is a revelation to them. Absolutely. And so this is what Moctezuma has to deal with, is the question of what lies beyond the sea? How many people are there? How readily can they get over here yes and these are questions that will obviously play a key part in the drama of what is about to happen so cortez continues down the valley and at the end of the valley again i'm simplifying a very complicated kind of lord of the rings style multi-chapter march there's this huge wall i mean it's extraordinary detail very middle earth it's a huge wall that runs across the sort of neck of the valley with a battlement on it and there's a narrow opening that leads into kind of shadow
但你是对的。他们从未猜到海的另一边会有其他人。这对他们来说是一个启示。绝对是。所以这就是蒙特祖马必须处理的问题，即海的另一边有什么？有多少人？他们能多容易地来到这里？是的，这些问题显然将在即将发生的事情的戏剧性中发挥关键作用。所以科尔特斯继续沿着山谷前进，在山谷的尽头，我再次简化了一场非常复杂的指环王式的多章节行军，有一堵巨大的墙，我的意思是，细节非常非凡，非常中土世界，这是一堵巨大的墙，横跨山谷的颈部，上面有城垛，有一个狭窄的开口通向某种阴影
and he leads his men through this opening and actually what they've done in crossing this wall they've gone into the lands of tlashcala and this is such a massive massive deal because tlashcala is a fascinating place. They speak the same language as the Mexica. So they're Nahuas, originally nomadic people from the north, from maybe Colorado or New Mexico or somewhere. As the Mexica were. Exactly.
他带领他的人穿过这个开口，实际上，他们穿过这堵墙，就进入了特拉斯卡拉（Tlaxcala）的土地，这真是一件大事，因为特拉斯卡拉是一个迷人的地方。他们说和墨西加人一样的语言。所以他们是纳瓦人，最初是来自北方的游牧民族，可能来自科罗拉多或新墨西哥州或其他地方。就像墨西加人一样。正是如此。
They have the same religion, effectively. They have the same customs, but they do not pay tribute to the Mexica. They are their own thing, their own little confederation of four cities, like a Greek city-state or something, the Tlaxcalans. The place of the tortillas, it means. Nice. That's a nice detail. Yeah.
他们实际上有相同的宗教。他们有相同的习俗，但他们不向墨西加人纳贡。他们是他们自己的东西，他们自己的四个城市的小联盟，就像希腊城邦之类的，特拉斯卡拉人。它的意思是玉米饼之地。不错。这是一个很好的细节。是的。
So they're completely enclosed by the Aztec Empire, which is actually a kind of triple alliance of three cities. So they're completely enclosed by the lands of the triple alliance. They don't pay tribute to them. They're stubbornly independent. They hate the Mexica with a passion passion and they fight these regular ritualistic flower wars as they're called we talked about them in our aztec podcast with camilla townsend didn't we
所以他们完全被阿兹特克帝国包围了，阿兹特克帝国实际上是三个城市的三方同盟。所以他们完全被三方同盟的土地包围了。他们不向他们纳贡。他们顽固地独立。他们极其痛恨墨西加人，他们进行这些定期的仪式性的花之战，正如我们和卡米拉·汤森在我们的阿兹特克播客中谈到的那样，不是吗？
they're a kind of combination of a dance a sporting occasion a religious ritual and a war all in one in which you capture your opponents. They're licensed by the Mexica because they know, I mean, it's certainly their high command know, probably not the mass of the people understand it, that it would be too great a challenge to destroy Tlaxcala. Yes. So they might as well kind of keep them playing this role, this subordinate role. Exactly. So once Cortes and his crowd get into Tlaxcalan territory, they are subject to daily running attacks from the Tlaxcalans. They've sent messengers to them, but the Tlaxcalans just lock them up. They don't know what to make of them at all. constantly attacking Cortes's party. And he and his men end up sort of established on a hill
它们是一种舞蹈、体育赛事、宗教仪式和战争的结合体，在其中你俘虏你的对手。它们得到了墨西加人的许可，因为他们知道，我的意思是，当然他们的最高指挥部知道，可能大多数人并不理解，摧毁特拉斯卡拉将是一个太大的挑战。是的。所以他们不妨让他们继续扮演这个角色，这个从属的角色。正是如此。所以一旦科尔特斯和他的随从进入特拉斯卡拉领土，他们就受到特拉斯卡拉人每日不断的袭击。他们派了信使给他们，但特拉斯卡拉人只是把他们关起来。他们根本不知道该拿他们怎么办。不断地攻击科尔特斯的队伍。他和他的手下最终在山上建立了一个据点
called Sompach Tepetl, and they are surrounded and they're always being attacked by these kind of roving bands of Tlaxcalans. They're running out of food. Weirdly, they're still getting gifts from Montezuma. Every now and again, an embassy from Montezuma will arrive with gifts and also saying to them, whatever you do, don't go into go into slash carly you'll all be killed these people are absolutely terrible so whether montezuma's men can pass on harassed across slash car and territory we don't know it's such a bizarre element of the story we also do know however that at this point cortez is already behaving very very ruthlessly so he and pedro de alberado his kind of chief lieutenant, are leading missions at night to go out to attack local villages, torture the priests, capture and mutilate the women and
叫松帕奇·特佩特尔（Sompach Tepetl），他们被包围了，总是受到这些特拉斯卡拉游击队的攻击。他们的食物快吃完了。奇怪的是，他们仍然收到蒙特祖马的礼物。每隔一段时间，蒙特祖马的使团就会带着礼物到达，并对他们说，无论你做什么，都不要进入特拉斯卡拉，你们都会被杀，这些人绝对可怕。所以蒙特祖马的人是否能穿过特拉斯卡拉领土而不受骚扰，我们不知道。这是故事中如此离奇的一个元素。然而，我们也确实知道，在这一点上，科尔特斯已经表现得非常非常无情，所以他和他的首席副官佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多（Pedro de Alvarado），带领着夜间任务出去攻击当地村庄，折磨祭司，俘虏并残害妇女和
children as a sort of warning to the Tlaxcalans. What will happen to them? Yes. This has been behavior that they developed in Hispaniola and Cuba. Exactly. At one point when they get attacked, this is where they aim the cannon. And because the Tlaxcalans are so packed, the impact is absolutely devastating. And in that particular battle, only one Spaniard died. Yeah. I mean, essentially, Cortes is marketing, isn't he?
儿童，作为对特拉斯卡拉人的一种警告。他们会发生什么？是的。这是他们在伊斯帕尼奥拉岛和古巴发展出来的行为。正是如此。有一次当他们受到攻击时，这就是他们瞄准大炮的地方。因为特拉斯卡拉人太密集了，冲击力绝对是毁灭性的。在那场特定的战斗中，只有一个西班牙人死亡。是的。我的意思是，本质上，科尔特斯是在营销，不是吗？
He's advertising to the Tlaxcalans, but also to the people beyond, to the Mexica, what he can do. This is his opportunity. Yeah. We have all this firepower. We are very violent. You know, you mess with us at your peril. What the Tlaxcalans are thinking, it's hard to say. I think a lot of historians think that they don't know what to make of Cortes and they're kind of testing him. Yeah. Is he worth allying with or indeed employing?
他是在向特拉斯卡拉人，也是向外面的人，向墨西加人，展示他能做什么。这是他的机会。是的。我们有所有的火力。我们非常暴力。你知道，你惹我们，后果自负。特拉斯卡拉人在想什么，很难说。我认为很多历史学家认为他们不知道该拿科尔特斯怎么办，他们是在试探他。是的。他值得结盟甚至雇佣吗？
Yes. Because at the point when the Spanish have run out of food, they're stuck on this hill, they're very miserable. They don't know where they are, what they're doing, and they're surrounded by these sort of hostile attackers. Just as their morale looks like it's going to crack, sort of mid-September this is, so they've been marching for weeks. The Tlaxcalans stop attacking and they send an emissary and they say, oh, let's actually be friends. Why don't you come into the city? We'll give you loads of gifts. This is when they first address Hernan Cortes as Malinche, which he finds very weird. And well, obviously Malinche is a key figure, by the way, in these negotiations. She must be doing all the talking because, I mean, it's not like Cortés is going to be doing it.
是的。因为在西班牙人食物耗尽的时候，他们被困在这座山上，他们非常痛苦。他们不知道自己在哪里，在做什么，而且他们被这些敌对的攻击者包围了。就在他们的士气看起来要崩溃的时候，大约是9月中旬，所以他们已经行军了几个星期。特拉斯卡拉人停止了攻击，他们派了一名特使，他们说，哦，让我们真的成为朋友吧。为什么不进城呢？我们会给你很多礼物。这就是他们第一次称呼埃尔南·科尔特斯为马林切的时候，他觉得这非常奇怪。而且，显然马林切在这些谈判中是一个关键人物，顺便说一下。她一定在做所有的谈话，因为，我的意思是，科尔特斯可不会去做。
And reassuring Cortés that the Tlaxcalans can be trusted and vice versa. Yeah. And the fact here, Tom, I think that thing that you said about her hating the Mexica, hating the Aztecs, that's really crucial because she's probably said to the Tlaxcala, we hate them. We will work for you. We will do whatever you want. So Cortes and his men are received in Tlaxcala in a weirdly jubilant festival atmosphere, given that they've just been fighting each other. There are lots of spectators in the streets. There's great cheering crowds, all this. They stay there for two or three weeks. They're wined and dined. The Tlaxcalans give them all brides. We don't know most of the brides, but we do know that Pedro de Alvarado was given a bride called Dona Luisa, who he took a
并向科尔特斯保证特拉斯卡拉人是可以信任的，反之亦然。是的。汤姆，我认为这里的事实，你说的关于她痛恨墨西加人、痛恨阿兹特克人的那件事，这非常关键，因为她可能对特拉斯卡拉人说，我们恨他们。我们会为你工作。我们会做任何你想要的事。所以科尔特斯和他的手下在特拉斯卡拉受到了一种奇怪的欢庆节日气氛的欢迎，考虑到他们刚刚还在互相战斗。街上有许多观众。有巨大的欢呼人群，所有这些。他们在那儿待了两三个星期。他们受到款待。特拉斯卡拉人给了他们所有新娘。我们不知道大多数新娘是谁，但我们确实知道佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多被送了一位叫多娜·路易莎（Dona Luisa）的新娘，他非常
great fancy to. And she actually accompanied him in his later, spoiler alert, he lives. So he went on later expeditions, killing loads of people in Guatemala and stuff. She came with him. And they're still buried together in a church in Antigua de Guatemala, I think it is. Anyway, the Tlaxcalans say, we'd like to do a deal with you. And this is an absolutely massive, massive world historical moment, I would say. For Orthodox historians, they see this as the moment that Cortes recruits the Tlaxcalans as allies in his crusade of conquest. But I think,
喜欢她。她确实陪同他参加了后来的探险，剧透警告，他活了下来。所以他后来参加了探险，在危地马拉等地杀死了很多人。她和他一起来了。我想他们现在还合葬在危地马拉安提瓜的一座教堂里。无论如何，特拉斯卡拉人说，我们想和你做一笔交易。我认为这是一个绝对巨大的、世界历史性的时刻。对于正统历史学家来说，他们认为这是科尔特斯在征服十字军东征中招募特拉斯卡拉人作为盟友的时刻。但我认为，
I agree with what they call the new conquest historiography, that it's actually the other way around. This is the moment that Tlaxcalans recruit the Spaniards as mercenaries. But it can be both, can't it? Exactly. Both have an investment in this. But I think the key thing though, Tom, I think it is both by the way, and I don't think the Spanish really understand what's being asked of them. But I think the key thing is the people with the real power in this exchange are the Tlaxcalans, not the Spanish.
我同意他们所说的“新征服史学”，即实际上恰恰相反。这是特拉斯卡拉人招募西班牙人作为雇佣兵的时刻。但这可以是双向的，不是吗？正是如此。双方对此都有投入。但我认为关键点在于，汤姆，我认为这确实是双向的，而且我不认为西班牙人真正理解他们被要求做什么。但我认为关键在于，这次交换中真正拥有权力的人是特拉斯卡拉人，而不是西班牙人。
Of course, because they've got vast, vast forces and there aren't that many Spaniards. Yeah. They've got all the troops, they've got all the food. And presumably this must have been part of Melinche's thinking from the beginning. I mean, she must have told Cortes because I don't believe that Cortes would have launched this invasion unless he'd thought there was a serious chance that he could pick up allies. And Malinche would have identified the Tlaxcalans. Yes, I'm sure you're right. As the obvious people. I'm sure you're right. And the other reason that I think it's the Tlaxcalans calling the shots more than the Spanish is what the Spanish do next. Because instead of heading straight to this Nostradamus, they turn south towards the city of Cholula. I was in Cholula actually
当然，因为他们拥有庞大的军队，而西班牙人并不多。是的。他们拥有所有的军队，他们拥有所有的食物。而且这大概从一开始就是马林切想法的一部分。我的意思是，她一定告诉了科尔特斯，因为我不相信科尔特斯会发动这次入侵，除非他认为他有很大的机会可以拉拢盟友。而马林切会认出特拉斯卡拉人。是的，我相信你是对的。作为显而易见的人选。我相信你是对的。而我认为特拉斯卡拉人比西班牙人更能掌控局面的另一个原因是西班牙人接下来所做的事情。因为他们没有直接前往诺斯特拉达姆，而是转向南，前往乔卢拉（Cholula）市。汤姆，我实际上在
earlier this year, Tom. It's a lovely little place. Even then, it was regarded as the most beautiful city in Mexico. It has this great pilgrimage center. It has this great pyramid, bigger than the pyramids in Egypt, which is now covered with earth. So it's an enormous hill, a man-made hill, basically. It's got a church at the top now. Like Silbury Hill in Wiltshire. It's better than Silbury, Tom. I hate to tell you. I doubt it. I doubt it. It was very well known because it had a massive temple of Quetzalcoatl, the feathered serpent, and pilgrims would go there from everywhere. Now, Cholula had recently been an ally of Tlaxcala, but had just changed sides, the Rotas to back Tenochtitlan. And clearly, I think, and modern historians think, that what the Tlaxcans were doing was they were basically unleashing the Spanish
今年早些时候去过乔卢拉。那是一个可爱的小地方。即使在当时，它也被认为是墨西哥最美丽的城市。它有一个伟大的朝圣中心。它有一座伟大的金字塔，比埃及的金字塔还要大，现在被泥土覆盖了。所以它基本上是一座巨大的山，一座人造山。现在上面有一座教堂。就像威尔特郡的西尔伯里山（Silbury Hill）。汤姆，它比西尔伯里山更好。我不想告诉你。我怀疑。我怀疑。它非常出名，因为它有一座巨大的羽蛇神（Quetzalcoatl）神庙，来自各地的朝圣者都会去那里。现在，乔卢拉最近是特拉斯卡拉的盟友，但刚刚倒戈，转向支持特诺奇蒂特兰。显然，我认为，现代历史学家也认为，特拉斯卡拉人所做的是，他们基本上是在释放西班牙人
on the Cholulans, but without the Spanish realizing it. So the story that we have in the sources is the Spanish arrive in Cholula and the Cholulans are a bit wary of them, but they're giving them hospitality and food and stuff. And then Malinche comes to Cortes and says, oh, I've heard terrible news from the Tlaxcalans. The Cholulans are actually working for the Aztecs and they're going to attack us at any moment. And Cortes, as he always does, says, well, this is not the Vicarage Tea Party. Let's kill them all. And they do. So the next day, the Spanish gather to leave. The Cholulans gather to see them off. And Cortes turns on them with his Tlaxcalan allies, because he now has this huge army of
去对付乔卢拉人，但西班牙人并没有意识到这一点。所以我们在资料中得到的故事是，西班牙人到达乔卢拉，乔卢拉人对他们有点警惕，但他们给予他们款待和食物之类的。然后马林切来到科尔特斯说，哦，我从特拉斯卡拉人那里听到了可怕的消息。乔卢拉人实际上是在为阿兹特克人工作，他们随时准备攻击我们。科尔特斯，像他一贯做的那样，说，好吧，这不是牧师茶会。让我们杀了他们所有人。他们确实这样做了。所以第二天，西班牙人聚集准备离开。乔卢拉人聚集来送行。科尔特斯带着他的特拉斯卡拉盟友转向他们，因为他现在拥有这支庞大的军队
Tlaxcanans that are marching along with him. And they sack the city for days. They burn the city. They turn people into slaves. There's a kind of orgy of rape and pillage. Sort of really, really terrible scenes. So again, I don't see any contradiction between the traditional historiography and the more revisionist historiography here because absolutely the Tlaxcalans want the Spanish to do their dirty work for them. They are the cutting edge. This is the Toledo sword that the Tlaxcalans have picked up. At the same time, Cortes has every stake in making as brutal and bloody a statement as he can, doesn't he? I mean, this is a warning to the Mexica. This is what we can do. He's been served up with the perfect opportunity to demonstrate what he and the Spaniards are
特拉斯卡拉人正随他行军。他们洗劫了这座城市好几天。他们烧毁了这座城市。他们把人变成奴隶。有一种强奸和掠夺的狂欢。那种非常非常可怕的场景。所以，我在这里没有看到传统史学和更修正主义史学之间的任何矛盾，因为特拉斯卡拉人绝对希望西班牙人为他们做脏活。他们是尖刀。这是特拉斯卡拉人捡起的托莱多剑。与此同时，科尔特斯有充分的理由做出尽可能残酷和血腥的声明，不是吗？我的意思是，这是对墨西加人的警告。这就是我们能做的。他得到了完美的展示他和西班牙人
capable of. Yeah, I think that's true. I also think, by the way, it's perfectly plausible. The whole story is plausible that Malinche came to him and said, you're going to be attacked and that he was worried. I don't necessarily think he has to be ruthlessly called. I mean, he can be frightened. He can be legitimately frightened and worried.
能力的绝佳机会。是的，我认为那是真的。顺便说一下，我也认为这是完全可信的。整个故事是可信的，马林切来到他身边说，你们要被攻击了，他很担心。我不一定认为他必须是冷酷无情的。我的意思是，他可以感到害怕。他可以合法地感到害怕和担心。
Of course, of course. But I do think that he has decided that he's going to become a player in what he must be very rapidly realizing is quite a complicated game. And I would guess that he would think, I have no possibility of success unless I establish myself as the most terrifying player on the board game, I would guess. Yeah. I think the really fascinating thing about Cortes is that Cortes, he's one of those characters who the violence, the ruthlessness, it's kind of learned behavior to an extent. He grew up in the Reconquista. He, as a young man, seen the violence in Hispaniola and Cuba, but he doesn't seem to be massively involved in it. What makes him a great opportunist in a very chilling and bloodthirsty way is that it's no holds barred with him.
当然，当然。但我确实认为他已经决定他要成为他一定很快意识到是一个相当复杂的游戏中的参与者。我会猜想他会认为，除非我把自己确立为棋盘上最可怕的玩家，否则我没有成功的可能性。是的。我认为关于科尔特斯真正迷人的地方在于，科尔特斯，他是那种暴力、无情在某种程度上是习得行为的角色。他在收复失地运动中长大。他作为一个年轻人，在伊斯帕尼奥拉岛和古巴看到了暴力，但他似乎并没有大规模参与其中。是什么让他成为一个以非常令人不寒而栗和嗜血的方式成为伟大的机会主义者，是因为他毫无顾忌。
Well, it's not to justify him, but he has no choice. He's made his decision. He's now a player in this game and he has to play as hard as he possibly can. Yeah. Because otherwise he's tostada. He is tostada, Tom. He would be tostada, but he's not because he carries out this massacre in Cholula. Then he and his men turn and they go towards the ring of mountains that
好吧，这不是为了证明他的正当性，但他别无选择。他做出了决定。他现在是这个游戏中的参与者，他必须尽可能努力地玩。是的。因为否则他就是烤饼（tostada）。汤姆，他是烤饼。他会是烤饼，但他不是，因为他在乔卢拉进行了那场屠杀。然后他和他的手下转身，他们走向环绕
surrounds the Valley of Mexico. There's a lot of faffing around with different routes and stuff, which will gloss over. They end up going between the two great volcanoes, the White Woman and the Smoking Man, they're called, two great volcanoes that kind of overlook the Valley of Mexico. They go up and when they get up there, they can see down through the clouds, there's pine forests, and then they see this extraordinary site, one of the great centers of world civilization, like Mesopotamia or the River Indus or something. And that is the Valley of Mexico. It looks like a sort of a colossal patchwork of fields and farms surrounded by mountains and villages. One and a half million people.
墨西哥谷的山脉。关于不同的路线等有很多折腾，我们将略过。他们最终走在两座伟大的火山之间，白女人和冒烟的人，他们被称为，两座俯瞰墨西哥谷的伟大火山。他们走上去，当他们到达那里时，他们可以看到云层下方，有松树林，然后他们看到了这个非凡的景象，世界文明的伟大中心之一，就像美索不达米亚或印度河或其他什么地方。那就是墨西哥谷。它看起来像是一个巨大的田野和农场拼凑而成，被山脉和村庄环绕。一百五十万人。
Yeah, exactly that. On a scale that they've never seen in Europe. And at the center of it, this huge sparkling lake. And at the center of the lake, this island with causeways stretching like a spider's web in every direction to the shores of the lake, floating gardens, hundreds and thousands of canoes, and clearly, as you say, hundreds and hundreds of thousands of people living in the lake and the lake towns and the capital. About 50,000, I think, the population of the city itself is.
是的，正是那样。规模是他们在欧洲从未见过的。在它的中心，这个巨大的波光粼粼的湖泊。在湖的中心，这个岛屿，堤道像蜘蛛网一样向四面八方延伸到湖岸，浮动花园，成百上千的独木舟，显然，正如你所说，成千上万的人生活在湖泊和湖畔城镇以及首都。我想城市本身的人口大约是5万。
I think it's bigger than 50,000. I mean, historians have wildly different estimates. So they go from, that's probably the low point, to maybe 200,000, the biggest. But generally, in the conurbation, the metropolitan area, there must be at least a million people. And the Spanish say, in their accounts, Seville just looked like a village compared with this. So although they're technologically more advanced than the Mexica, the Mexica towns astound them. Absolutely astound them, absolutely astound them. All the way that they're going, they're being given more and more gifts. So they're getting mixed messages.
我认为它比5万大。我的意思是，历史学家的估计差异很大。所以他们从，那可能是低点，到也许20万，最大的。但通常，在城市群，大都市区，至少有一百万人。西班牙人在他们的记录中说，塞维利亚与此相比就像一个村庄。所以尽管他们在技术上比墨西加人更先进，但墨西加城镇让他们震惊。绝对让他们震惊，绝对让他们震惊。他们一路走来，被给予越来越多的礼物。所以他们得到了混合的信息。
They're getting gifts on the one hand, but they're also getting messengers who say to them, Montezuma is far too busy to see you. He really thinks you should turn back now and go back to the coast. And the Spanish, they are completely bewildered by this. I think they have no idea how to make sense of the messages they have been given by the Mexica. And I think it's kind of proved a challenge, hasn't it, more generally for historians ever since to make sense of it. And it's much contested. Yeah, because what we don't know is, are the Mexica really trying to deter them from coming? Or are they trying to encourage them? I mean, we will come to this actually actually, Tom. We should discuss this. Yes, we will.
他们一方面得到礼物，但他们也得到信使，他们对他们说，蒙特祖马太忙了，没法见你。他真的认为你们现在应该回头，回到海岸。西班牙人，他们对此完全感到困惑。我认为他们根本不知道如何理解墨西加人给他们的信息。而且我认为这有点证明是一个挑战，不是吗，更广泛地对历史学家来说，从那时起就一直试图理解它。而且它非常有争议。是的，因为我们不知道的是，墨西加人是真的在试图阻止他们到来吗？还是他们在试图鼓励他们？我的意思是，我们实际上会谈到这一点，汤姆。我们应该讨论这个。是的，我们会。
We will. Maybe we should take a break. And the final stage of the Spaniards' journey, the amazing scenes of them crossing the lake, crossing the causeway, getting to see the emperor. I mean, the most unbelievable meeting in world history. Yes. And then what happens next?
我们会。也许我们应该休息一下。西班牙人旅程的最后阶段，他们穿过湖泊、穿过堤道、见到皇帝的惊人场景。我的意思是，世界历史上最令人难以置信的会面。是的。然后接下来发生了什么？
Okay, so we'll see you in a few minutes. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment
好的，那我们几分钟后再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的帷幕
and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. to live tickets head to the rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com when we saw it we could scarcely believe our eyes and as we gazed on the enchanted stone castles the soaring pyramids and the fairy tale towers rising from the waters. We thought it was a magical scene from the Book of Mardis, and some of our men wondered if they
我们告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。前往 therestisentertainment.com，那是 therestisentertainment.com。当我们看到它时，我们几乎不敢相信自己的眼睛，当我们凝视着迷人的石头城堡、高耸的金字塔和从水中升起的童话塔楼时。我们以为那是《马迪斯之书》（Book of Mardis）中的神奇场景，我们的一些人怀疑他们
were dreaming. So that was Bernal Diaz, whether he was lying or not, but his tone of wonder there, Dominic, is absolutely palpable. And he's describing this spectacular vision of the urban civilization of the Mexica and other peoples around the Great Lake of Mexico. I mean, an astonishing moment in world history. It is. You said, we don't know if he's lying. I think he's undoubtedly telling the truth there. Undoubtedly. He's blown away, isn't he? He is stunned by what he sees and they are all stunned. They are overwhelmed with the beauty of it. I mean, Venice is the only point of comparison that they can think of, but they have a kind of an awareness that they're looking at something so beautiful that it transcends the ability of
是否在做梦。所以那是贝尔纳·迪亚斯，无论他是否在撒谎，但多米尼克，他在那里的惊叹语气是绝对显而易见的。他正在描述墨西加人和其他围绕墨西哥大湖的民族的城市文明的壮观景象。我的意思是，世界历史上的一个惊人时刻。确实。你说，我们不知道他是否在撒谎。我认为他无疑是在那里说真话。无疑。他被震撼了，不是吗？他被他所看到的惊呆了，他们都被惊呆了。他们被它的美丽所淹没。我的意思是，威尼斯是他们能想到的唯一比较点，但他们有一种意识，即他们正在看的东西太美了，以至于超越了
Europeans to achieve it. And that is a crucial part of the tragedy that is to come, that they do value the beauty of what they're seeing. They do, absolutely. So they've been through a succession of lake towns that are clearly in a completely different league, either from the Maya settlements that they have seen on the coast, and certainly in a completely different league from what they've seen on Cuba and Hispaniola and Jamaica and the other islands that some of them may have visited.
欧洲人实现它的能力。这是即将到来的悲剧的关键部分，他们确实珍视他们所看到的这种美。他们确实，绝对。所以他们经过了一连串的湖畔城镇，这些城镇显然处于一个完全不同的级别，无论是从他们在海岸上看到的玛雅定居点，还是当然从他们在古巴、伊斯帕尼奥拉岛和牙买加以及他们中的一些人可能访问过的其他岛屿上看到的完全不同的级别。
This is more like, some of Bernal Diaz's comrades say to him, this is like Constantinople. I've been to Constantinople. I served in the army and whatever. I volunteered as a mercenary. I went on an embassy. This is like that. Or Rome. It's like nothing they had expected. And that place that they arrived at, so Iztapalapan, which is now a suburb, all of this area that we're describing, this lake, is now Mexico City. So you can drive through Iztapalapan and it's just kind of- Dusty, yeah. Mexico City slum stroke suburbia.
这更像是，贝尔纳·迪亚斯的一些同志对他说，这就像君士坦丁堡。我去过君士坦丁堡。我在军队服役，或者其他什么。我作为雇佣兵志愿参军。我去过大使馆。这就像那样。或者罗马。这不像他们预期的任何东西。他们到达的那个地方，所以伊斯塔帕拉帕（Iztapalapan），现在是一个郊区，我们描述的所有这个区域，这个湖，现在是墨西哥城。所以你可以开车穿过伊斯塔帕拉帕，它只是有点——尘土飞扬，是的。墨西哥城的贫民窟兼郊区。
Because as Bernal goes on to say, today everything that I saw has been torn down and destroyed. Nothing is left standing. And the tragedy of that, Tom, is that the Spanish themselves, who had gone through it in open-jawed am are gardens going down to the lake. And the gardens have ponds and they have channels. And the servants have clearly dug so that their masters and mistresses can sail their canoes down into the lake. And Diaz says of that, everything was so charming, so beautiful, that we could find no words to express our astonishment.
因为正如贝尔纳继续说的，今天我所看到的一切都被拆毁和摧毁了。什么都没有留下。汤姆，那其中的悲剧在于，西班牙人自己，他们曾张大嘴巴走过它，是通往湖泊的花园。花园有池塘，有水道。仆人们显然挖了水道，以便他们的主人和女主人可以划着独木舟进入湖中。迪亚斯对此说，一切都如此迷人，如此美丽，以至于我们找不到词语来表达我们的惊奇。
And as I stood there, I thought there was nowhere like it anywhere in the world. But all of this must be serving to just ratchet up the tension as they approach the city that lies at the heart of the Basin of Mexico. Because at the heart of the Basin of Mexico is the lake, and at the heart of the lake is an island. And on the island is the great capital of the Mexica, Tenochtitlan. And at the heart of Tenochtitlan are spectacular pyramids, temples, palaces. And so you have the sense that you are really going towards the heart of this fantastical world that they've entered into. Yeah. And they're advancing quite slowly. So they can see it in the distance, but they go from town to town.
当我站在那里时，我想世界上没有其他地方像它一样。但所有这一切一定只是在他们接近位于墨西哥盆地中心的城市时加剧了紧张局势。因为在墨西哥盆地的中心是湖泊，在湖泊的中心是一个岛屿。在岛上是墨西加人的伟大首都，特诺奇蒂特兰。在特诺奇蒂特兰的中心是壮观的金字塔、神庙、宫殿。所以你有一种感觉，你真的正在走向他们进入的这个奇幻世界的中心。是的。而且他们前进得相当缓慢。所以他们可以在远处看到它，但他们从一个城镇走到另一个城镇。
Getting nearer and nearer. Getting nearer and nearer. And there are now crowds. So every day now, they are being visited by emissaries from the capital, including a guy called Kakama, who is the king of Texcoco. Texcoco is the second city of the Triple Alliance. So it's the second big power of the Aztec Empire. And Kakama is Montezuma's nephew.
越来越近。越来越近。现在有人群了。所以现在每天，他们都受到来自首都的使者的访问，包括一个叫卡卡马（Kakama）的人，他是特斯科科（Texcoco）的国王。特斯科科是三方同盟的第二大城市。所以它是阿兹特克帝国的第二个大国。而卡卡马是蒙特祖马的侄子。
And he is brought to them in a litter as a sort of kingly figure. Again, he gives them very mixed messages. He addresses Cortes, Malinche again, calls him Malinche. And he says, everything that we have is yours. Our city is your home and all of this stuff. And then he also says, however, the emperor is ill and we don't think you should come any further, which Cortes and the Spaniards just think is weird.
他被带到他们面前，坐在轿子里，作为一种君王形象。同样，他给了他们非常混合的信息。他再次称呼科尔特斯为马林切，称他为马林切。他说，我们拥有的一切都是你的。我们的城市是你的家，所有这些东西。然后他还说，然而，皇帝病了，我们认为你不应该再往前走了，科尔特斯和西班牙人觉得这很奇怪。
They can't understand the very mixed messages because they can't understand the courtly formulas of elite speech, which is presumably what they are being given. So they've got the emissaries coming the whole time. They have crowds of spectators who are staring at their horses, the dogs, the men with the white faces and the red beards, as they're often described. At various points, some of the conquistadors have to beat back the crowds who are pressing in on them. Whether hostile or curious,
他们无法理解这些非常混合的信息，因为他们无法理解精英言论的宫廷套路，这大概就是他们被给予的东西。所以他们一直有使者到来。他们有成群的观众，他们盯着他们的马、狗、有着白脸和红胡子的人，正如他们经常被描述的那样。在不同的点，一些征服者不得不击退挤向他们的人群。无论是敌对还是好奇，
we don't know, and I don't think they know themselves. And finally, they've got to Itz to Balapan on the 7th of November, I think it is, 1519. And the next morning, the 8th of November, which has a case, I think, Tom, for being one of the landmark days in all world history. Most extraordinary days. Well, symbolic of so much that is to come. Imperialism, colonialism, yeah. A kind of pivot around which you could say world history spins. Absolutely, you could. So they set off. And they set off from Iztapalapan. And there's basically a causeway that leads to the city at the center of the lake on the island, about 10 miles.
我们不知道，我想他们自己也不知道。最后，他们在1519年11月7日到达了伊兹塔帕拉潘（Iztapalapan）。第二天，也就是11月8日，我认为汤姆，这一天在世界历史上具有里程碑意义。这是极其非凡的一天。嗯，它象征着即将到来的一切。帝国主义、殖民主义，是的。你可以说这是世界历史围绕其旋转的一个枢纽。绝对可以。所以他们出发了。他们从伊兹塔帕拉潘出发。基本上有一条堤道通往湖中心岛上的城市，大约10英里长。
And as they leave Iztapalapan, there are people staring at them. You can imagine, it's so weird for the Spanish to be trudging along. Some of them are riding their horses. Presumably, Dominic, they're also staring at the Tlaxcalans who are going as well. Yes. So, I mean, that's also part of the dynamic. You know, these bitter enemies are... Are there too.
当他们离开伊兹塔帕拉潘时，有人在盯着他们看。你可以想象，对于西班牙人来说，这样跋涉是非常奇怪的。他们中的一些人骑着马。多米尼克，想必他们也在盯着同样随行的特拉斯卡拉人（Tlaxcalans）。是的。所以，我的意思是，这也是动态的一部分。你知道，这些死敌也在那里……也在那里。
I mean, it's quite something to allow a whole load of Tlaxcalans into your city. Right, exactly. Which again is, how do we conceptualize that as historians? I don't know. I mean, it's very odd, isn't it? Yeah. If you were to set this in ancient Greece or Rome, what would the equivalent be? You know, a load of aliens marching into ancient Rome with the Carthaginians behind them.
我的意思是，让一大群特拉斯卡拉人进入你的城市真是非同寻常。没错，正是如此。这再次引出了一个问题：作为历史学家，我们该如何概念化这一点？我不知道。我的意思是，这非常奇怪，不是吗？是的。如果你把这个场景放在古希腊或罗马，等同于什么呢？你知道，一群外星人带着迦太基人走进了古罗马。
With the Persians. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Very odd. Yeah. So weird. And I don't think I've ever really read any historian who says, well, how are the Mexica dealing with the Tlaxcalans?
带着波斯人。是的，完全正确。是的。非常奇怪。是的。太诡异了。而且我不认为我读过任何历史学家说，嗯，墨西加人（Mexica）是如何对待特拉斯卡拉人的？
I can't think of anyone. Where do they put them up? Where are they going to sleep? Where do they stay? Yes. What are they saying to each other? Exactly. Nobody knows how to conceptualize this. It's like they're in a dream, a weird dream. I mean, the Spanish keep saying that. It's a dream. It's like we're in a novel. But it seems for the Mexica as well, that they cling to ritual, don't they? Yeah. So the Spanish, they turn up at some kind of great formal entry and all the noblemen are there and they keep kind of prostrating themselves, touching the ground. And it takes about an hour. It does. And Cortés gets very impatient with this. He is. Because the Spanish don't know what's going on. They've got one person who understands the language, Melinche, who's muttering in Cortés' ear the whole time. And the rest of the Spanish are bored, tired, frightened, excited, all these things.
我想不出有谁提到过。他们把他们安置在哪里？他们去哪里睡觉？他们住在哪里？是的。他们彼此在说什么？正是如此。没人知道如何概念化这一点。就像他们身处梦境，一个奇怪的梦。我的意思是，西班牙人一直在说。这是一个梦。就像我们身处小说中一样。但对于墨西加人来说，他们似乎也执着于仪式，不是吗？是的。所以西班牙人出现在某种盛大的正式入城仪式上，所有的贵族都在那里，他们不断地俯伏在地，触摸地面。这花了一个小时。确实。科尔特斯对此变得非常不耐烦。他确实如此。因为西班牙人不知道发生了什么。他们只有一个懂语言的人，马林切（Malinche），一直在科尔特斯耳边嘀咕。而其余的西班牙人感到无聊、疲惫、恐惧、兴奋，各种情绪交织。
Cortés has organized his men in ranks. He's at the front with the senior captains, with the Alvarado brothers. They have the standard with the cross. Then behind them, they've got the infantry, the horsemen, the crossbowmen, and then towards the back at Slashcarlans with all the porters and the slaves and so on and so forth. They cross these bridges. They cross these causeways. As you say, they are met by the nobles at a fort in the middle of the lake on a kind of outcrop. And this is a point where the causeways meet. And then they advance towards the city, towards the main gate. And there, there are ranks and ranks of what are called the Jaguar Knights, elite warriors.
科尔特斯把他的手下编成了队列。他与高级队长们，还有阿尔瓦拉多（Alvarado）兄弟走在最前面。他们带着十字架旗帜。在他们后面是步兵、骑兵、弩手，再往后是带着搬运工和奴隶等等的特拉斯卡拉人。他们穿过这些桥梁。他们穿过这些堤道。正如你所说，他们在湖中间的一个露头堡垒处被贵族们迎接。这是堤道交汇的地方。然后他们向城市推进，向主门推进。在那里，有成排成排的所谓“美洲豹武士”，即精英战士。
That's a great name, isn't it? Yeah. Brilliant name. I'd love a Jaguar Knights if I were a king. And from their ranks, a litter comes forward. It's been carried by the great dignitaries of the Aztec Empire. And there's a man on it with a massive green feathered headdress. And this, of course, is Motekuzuma Shokoyotsin. Or I would call him Montezuma.
那是个很棒的名字，不是吗？是的。绝妙的名字。如果我是国王，我也想要美洲豹武士。从他们的队列中，一顶轿子走了出来。它由阿兹特克帝国的大臣们抬着。上面坐着一个人，戴着巨大的绿色羽毛头饰。这当然就是蒙特祖马·索科约特辛（Motekuzuma Shokoyotsin）。或者我会叫他蒙特祖马（Montezuma）。
I would call him Moctezuma. Would you? You're so much woker than I am, Tom. Is that woker? I think it's more Spanish. I think it's more Spanish. It's a Spanish pronunciation, isn't it? Yeah.
我会叫他莫克特祖马（Moctezuma）。你会吗？汤姆，你比我更“觉醒”（woke）得多。那是“觉醒”吗？我认为这更接近西班牙语。我认为这更接近西班牙语。这是西班牙语发音，不是吗？是的。
You're just such a continental. I am. Yes. You're a citizen of nowhere. Let's be honest. Can I read you Camilla Townsend's beautiful description? Do. Over him, his retainers held a magnificent canopy,
你真是个欧陆派。我是。是的。老实说，你是个无国籍公民。我可以读给你听卡米拉·汤森（Camilla Townsend）那段优美的描述吗？请读。在他上方，他的随从撑着一把华丽的华盖，
a great arc pointing towards the sky, its bits of gold and precious stones glinting in the light. Amazing moment. Amazing moment. I mean, it must have been. We should say something about this bloke on the litter. The image that you get in all the sort of standard sort of popular histories or the kids' books and stuff. Like yours?
一个指向天空的巨大弧形，金子和宝石在光线下闪烁。令人惊叹的时刻。令人惊叹的时刻。我的意思是，那一定是的。我们应该谈谈轿子上的这个家伙。你在所有那种标准的通俗历史或儿童读物中看到的形象。像你的书那样？
Not like mine, Tom. No. So this is why Adventures in Time cut above. Yeah. It's revisionist wokery. That's what my books represent. But in the standard books, the person on the litter is a terrible drip. Yes. Well, he's Boabdil, isn't he? We talked about the Moorish king who surrenders the Alhambra. And you have to wonder whether that perhaps is part of the historiographical influence on how Moctezuma is presented. But Moctezuma, I mean, do you want us to say the Nahuatl name again, his actual name? Moctezuma Shocoyotzin, Tom.
不像我的，汤姆。不。所以这就是《时间冒险》（Adventures in Time）高人一等的地方。是的。这是修正主义的“觉醒”。这就是我的书所代表的。但在标准书籍中，轿子上的人是个糟糕的软蛋。是的。嗯，他是博阿布迪尔（Boabdil），不是吗？我们谈到了投降阿尔罕布拉宫的摩尔国王。你不得不怀疑这是否是影响莫克特祖马形象的历史编纂的一部分。但莫克特祖马，我的意思是，你想让我们再说一遍纳瓦特尔语名字，他真正的名字吗？莫克特祖马·索科约特辛，汤姆。
So apparently this means frowns like a lord. Yeah. And he does frown, doesn't he? He's a hard ruler. He's a hard rider. He is a really, really formidable and impressive and terrifying man. He has been the high speaker, the great king of the Mexica, the emperor of this realm for about 17 years. And Dominic, I mean, worth saying that there isn't a kind of, you know,
所以这显然意味着“像领主一样皱眉”。是的，他确实皱眉，不是吗？他是一位严厉的统治者。他是一位强硬的骑手。他确实是一个非常、非常强大、令人印象深刻且可怕的人。他担任最高发言人，墨西加人的伟大国王，这个王国的皇帝已经大约17年了。多米尼克，我的意思是，值得一提的是，并没有那种，你知道，
it's not primogeniture. You have to be held worthy of becoming king. Yeah, absolutely. From admittedly a kind of, you know, quite a small pool of candidates, but he's been chosen as king because people think that he's the best qualified for it. And everything over the course of his 17 year reign suggests that he is indeed a man who is very, very proficient at the art of ruling. He's very good at it. Because as I understand it, he has been supervising the emergence of the Aztec empire as a kind of loose, inchoate order into something that would be more familiar and say to the Europeans, a kind of state. He's been engaged in the process of building the infrastructure of a state. Although all those are kind of very anachronistic ways of describing it, but basically
这不是长子继承制。你必须被认为有资格成为国王。是的，绝对。虽然承认是在一个相当小的候选人池中，但他被选为国王是因为人们认为他是最合格的。在他17年的统治期间，一切都表明他确实是一个非常、非常精通统治艺术的人。他非常擅长。因为据我理解，他一直在监督阿兹特克帝国从一种松散、未成形的秩序向一种欧洲人更熟悉的东西，即一种国家形式的演变。他一直致力于构建国家基础设施的过程。尽管这些都是非常时代错乱的描述方式，但基本上
that's what he's been doing. It is. This is totally different, totally different from the situation when the Spanish arrive in Peru with the Incas, where the Incas are all divided and feuding among themselves. With the Aztecs, with the Mexica, they are united and he is a really, really impressive guy. He has done a good job. He has been utterly formidable. He's expanded their frontiers. He's faced rebellions and he's crushed them mercilessly. He's sent out new officials to gather tribute. He's done all these things. And the version that you often get, and certainly that I was brought up with, which is this quivering weed who can't wait to surrender his kingdom to the Spaniards,
这就是他一直在做的。确实。这与西班牙人到达秘鲁面对印加人的情况完全不同，印加人当时四分五裂，互相争斗。对于阿兹特克人，对于墨西加人来说，他们是团结的，他是一个非常、非常令人印象深刻的家伙。他做得很好。他一直非常强大。他扩大了他们的疆域。他面对叛乱并无情地镇压了它们。他派出了新的官员去征收贡品。他做了所有这些事情。而你经常看到的版本，当然也是我从小听到的版本，即他是一个迫不及待地想把王国投降给西班牙人的颤抖的杂草，
who he thinks are gods. And he's terrified of Cortes, terrified of Charles V, bursts into tears at the sight of a beard. That's just plain wrong. It's utterly implausible. Right. But he's not a coward, but it is also his duty to preserve his people. And so if he feels that he is facing a threat that is maybe beyond his capacity to cope with, then that is also something that has to be factored in. And again, kind of going back to the science fiction analogy, if you're the president in the White House, maybe you can deal with two or three flying saucers. But if there's a whole battle
他认为他们是神。他害怕科尔特斯，害怕查理五世，一看到胡子就泪流满面。这简直是错的。这完全不可信。没错。但他不是懦夫，但保护他的人民也是他的职责。所以如果他觉得他面临的威胁可能超出了他的应对能力，那么这也是必须考虑的因素。再次回到科幻小说的类比，如果你是白宫的总统，也许你能应付两三艘飞碟。但如果有一整支战斗
fleet of flying saucers and they're all armed with terrifying ray guns or whatever, then it's a different matter, isn't it? It is. But does he think at that point there are going to be loads of them? I'm not sure he does. No, he doesn't know. But I think that it is sensible for him to kind of scope it out. Don't you think? And likewise with Cortez. I mean, I think that these are like dogs that are sniffing each other's bottoms. Yes. Right. That's a lovely image. No, I think there's lots of truth in that. I think Montezuma is sort of thinking, let's see what's going on here. This is something that's not happened before. You know, it's not in our histories, which they take very seriously, the Aztecs.
飞碟舰队，而且它们都装备着可怕的射线枪什么的，那情况就不同了，不是吗？确实。但他当时认为会有很多这样的飞碟吗？我不确定他是否这样想。不，他不知道。但我认为他去探查一下是明智的。你不觉得吗？科尔特斯也是如此。我的意思是，我认为这就像两只狗在互相闻对方的屁股。是的。没错。那是个可爱的形象。不，我认为其中有很多真理。我认为蒙特祖马是在想，让我们看看这里发生了什么。这是以前从未发生过的事情。你知道，这不在我们的历史中，阿兹特克人非常重视历史。
Yeah. It's not in the rule book. Yeah, it's not in the books. This is new. But he is a politician. He's used to negotiating with other city-states. You know, he knows there's a big world out there. He didn't know there were people beyond the sea. But also, Dominic, he also knows that his people are hated, doesn't he? So if the Tlaxcalans are there, he knows that he has to maintain his authority, his power, but equally, he has to be aware that they're camped out on the edge of a volcano.
是的。这不在规则手册里。是的，不在书里。这是新的。但他是一位政治家。他习惯于与其他城邦谈判。你知道，他知道外面有一个广阔的世界。他不知道海那边还有人。但多米尼克，他也知道他的人民被憎恨，不是吗？所以如果特拉斯卡拉人在那里，他知道他必须维持他的权威、他的权力，但同样，他必须意识到他们正驻扎在火山边缘。
Well. I mean, literally. Yes, they are. But this is the whole dynamic of Mesoamerican polities, is that empires rise and then they disintegrate because the constituent parts are so ready to kind of jump ship. Yeah. And that's happened many times because the Mexika themselves were the vassals of a people called the tepeneks and there were lots of civilizations before so they do have a very
嗯。我的意思是，字面上看。是的，他们是。但这就是中美洲政体的全部动态，帝国兴起，然后因为组成部分随时准备“跳船”而瓦解。是的。这种情况发生过很多次，因为墨西加人自己曾经是被称为特帕内克人（Tepeneks）的附庸，而且之前有很多文明，所以他们确实有一种非常
strong sense don't they camilla tanza makes this point of a cycle of death and rebirth and all this so they don't want to be on the death side of that no montezuma is very friendly to cortez at first i mean in his own way. So they greet each other. Cortez actually goes to embrace him. Cortez goes to give him a hug. I know. So Theo, our producer of course, is a Frenchman. So he just spends the whole time rushing around trying to hug people and give them kisses and it's endlessly embarrassing. Montezuma is much more Anglo-Saxon, isn't he? Very stiff.
强烈的意识，不是吗？卡米拉·汤森指出了这一点，关于死亡与重生的循环等等，所以他们不想成为其中的死亡方。不，蒙特祖马起初对科尔特斯非常友好，我的意思是，以他自己的方式。所以他们互相问候。科尔特斯实际上去拥抱他。科尔特斯去给他一个拥抱。我知道。所以西奥（Theo），我们的制片人当然是法国人。所以他整天跑来跑去试图拥抱人们并亲吻他们，这总是令人尴尬。蒙特祖马更像盎格鲁-撒克逊人，不是吗？非常僵硬。
He is because Cortez goes to embrace him. And the two guys who are carrying Montezuma is much more Anglo-Saxon, isn't he? Very stiff. He is, because Cortez goes to embrace him. And the two guys who are carrying Montezuma's litter, who are his brother, Kuitlahuek, and his nephew, Kakama, who are these two great people on whom he relies, they kind of warn Cortez off. No, back off, mate. Yeah, stand back, please. But Cortez gives Montezuma a necklace.
他确实如此，因为科尔特斯去拥抱他。而抬着蒙特祖马轿子的两个人，也就是他的兄弟奎特拉瓦克（Kuitlahuek）和他的侄子卡卡马（Kakama），这两个他所依赖的伟大人物，他们警告科尔特斯退后。不，退后，伙计。是的，请退后。但科尔特斯给了蒙特祖马一条项链。
Montezuma gives Cortez another necklace of red snail shells with little solid-grawled kind of shrimps. I mean, what they say to each other is incredibly controversial among historians. But clearly, Cortes says, are you him? Are you Montezuma? Malinche is translating all this. Yes, says Montezuma. And then it seems to me anyway that Montezuma says something like this.
蒙特祖马给了科尔特斯另一条项链，上面有红色蜗牛壳和小的实心金虾。我的意思是，他们对彼此说的话在历史学家中极具争议。但显然，科尔特斯说，你是他吗？你是蒙特祖马吗？马林切正在翻译这一切。是的，蒙特祖马说。然后在我看来，蒙特祖马说了类似这样的话。
He says something like, welcome, my Lord. You must be very weary. You've traveled far, but this is your home now. Your coming has been, well, does he say your coming has been foretold, been prophesied? Or does he say- I've been told you're coming. We were told that you were coming. Yes, because they're very different.
他说，欢迎，我的领主。您一定很累了。您远道而来，但这里现在是您的家。您的到来已经被，嗯，他说您的到来是被预言的吗？还是他说——我被告知您要来。我们被告知您要来。是的，因为它们非常不同。
He says, the city, our city, the city of the Mexica is yours now. I will show you to your house where you may rest. Welcome, my lord. And Cortes probably thinks, okay, this is probably more effusive than I was expecting, but fine. So Montezuma leads Cortes into the city through the gates. I mean, you can imagine how utterly overwhelming it must have been because there are people on all the rooftops. There are huge crowds, there are drummers, there's trumpets, there's flutes, there's the whole works. I mean, there's massive capital. They get a glimpse of this central square with huge pyramid temples reaching to the skies and skull racks. Skull racks, exactly. I mean, as a sensory overload. And don't forget,
他说，这座城市，我们的城市，墨西加人的城市现在是您的了。我会带您去您的住所，在那里您可以休息。欢迎，我的领主。科尔特斯可能心想，好吧，这可能比我预期的更热情，但没关系。所以蒙特祖马带着科尔特斯穿过大门进入城市。我的意思是，你可以想象这一定有多么令人震撼，因为屋顶上全是人。有巨大的人群，有鼓手，有小号，有长笛，应有尽有。我的意思是，这是一个巨大的首都。他们瞥见了中央广场，那里有巨大的金字塔神庙直插云霄，还有头骨架。头骨架，正是如此。我的意思是，这是一种感官过载。别忘了，
they've been marching for weeks. I mean, they're knackered and hungry and wet and dirty and all of this. Montezuma takes them to a sort of mansion, which is called the Palace of Axeia Cattle, which is his father's old palace. And he takes them into this dining room where there's two thrones and there are servants waiting with tortillas and turkey and fruit and eggs and all this. And he says, crack on, get stuck in. So they then eat and drink their fill. And then Montezuma returns for this incredibly, incredibly significant moment where he gives a speech to them. If you read Hugh Thomas' book, Conquest, for example, or you read Cortes' letters, or you read Bernal Diaz, they will tell you, this is the moment when Montezuma says to Cortes, you have arrived and it was foretold. I surrender my kingdom to
他们已经行军数周了。我的意思是，他们筋疲力尽、饥肠辘辘、浑身湿透、肮脏不堪，所有这些。蒙特祖马把他们带到了一座被称为阿克萨卡特尔宫（Palace of Axeia Cattle）的宅邸，这是他父亲的老宫殿。他把他们带进这个餐厅，那里有两把宝座，仆人们端着玉米饼、火鸡、水果、鸡蛋等等等着。他说，吃吧，尽情享用。所以他们吃喝饱足。然后蒙特祖马回来进行了这个极其、极其重要的时刻，他向他们发表了演讲。如果你读休·托马斯（Hugh Thomas）的书《征服》（Conquest），或者你读科尔特斯的信件，或者你读贝尔纳尔·迪亚斯（Bernal Diaz），他们会告诉你，这就是蒙特祖马对科尔特斯说，你已经到达，这是预言中的时刻。我把我的王国投降给
you. I acknowledge the king of Spain as my overlord. I am his vassal. This is your kingdom now. Well done. You've won. And I don't know about you, Tom, but I find that, like most modern historians, I find that utterly implausible. Yeah. I mean, because it clearly is. So one could advance all kinds of ways of saying how Cortes might have arrived at that. So we talked about the legal requirements. He first pens this story, doesn't he, in a letter to Charles V back in Spain. And he's writing that at a time where everything seems to have gone completely wrong. So, spoiler alert, the Spanish feel that they've been expelled, lots of them have been killed. Moctezuma himself is dead by this point. If Cortes can present to the Spanish king the fact that he is defending the Spanish king's lands, that Moctezuma has given them to the Spanish king, then that makes him seem a heroic defender of the Spanish king's cause, rather than a guy who has gone on a harebrained scheme
你。我承认西班牙国王是我的领主。我是他的附庸。这现在是您的王国了。干得好。您赢了。我不知道你怎么想，汤姆，但我发现，像大多数现代历史学家一样，我发现这完全不可信。是的。我的意思是，因为它显然是。所以人们可以提出各种方式来说明科尔特斯是如何得出这个结论的。所以我们谈到了法律要求。他首先在写给西班牙查理五世的一封信中编造了这个故事，不是吗？他写那封信的时候，一切似乎都完全搞砸了。所以，剧透警告，西班牙人觉得他们被驱逐了，很多人被杀了。莫克特祖马本人此时已经死了。如果科尔特斯能向西班牙国王展示他正在保卫西班牙国王的土地，莫克特祖马已经把它们交给了西班牙国王，那么这使他看起来像是西班牙国王事业的英雄捍卫者，而不是一个搞砸了所有事情、违抗命令的鲁莽计划的家伙。所以这将是其中的一部分。但想必，你谈到了莫克特祖马在问候客人时那种稍微华丽的正式语言。我的意思是，本质上，你知道，这就是“我的家就是您的家”。是的，正是那样，不是吗？再次，我的意思是，你可以说科尔特斯是有意曲解了这一点。他抓住这一点，然后将其旋转和营销，或者也许他真的误解了。也许马林切在为他旋转。有太多的交叉电流，有太多的误解机会。当然，还有记忆的回溯效应。
in defiance of orders and everything's gone wrong. So that would be one part of it. But presumably also, you talk about the slightly flowery quality of the formal language of Moctezuma in greeting his guests. I mean, essentially, you know, it's mi casa es su casa. Yeah, it's exactly that, isn't it? And again, I mean, you could say that Cortez is willfully misinterpreting that. He fixes on that as something that he can then spin and market, or perhaps he genuinely misunderstands it. Perhaps Malinche is spinning it for him. There are so many cross currents, there's so many opportunities for misinterpretation. And of course, the retrospective effect of memory.
如果你迫切需要并想要相信某件事，那么你的记忆就会玩弄把戏。我认为正是那样。我认为你是绝对正确的。马修·雷斯特尔（Matthew Restle），他写了几本关于这个的书，一本关于科尔特斯和蒙特祖马的会面，另一本关于，我想是《西班牙征服的七大迷思》。我发现读那些书是我在历史编纂学上最令人兴奋的经历之一。我同意。
If you desperately need and want to believe something, then your memory can play tricks. I think it's exactly that. I think you're absolutely right. Matthew Restle, he's written a couple of books on this, one on the meeting of Cortes and Montezuma, and one on, I think, Seven Myths of the Spanish Conquest, he calls it. And I found reading those books one of the most intellectually exciting historiographical experiences. I agree. I read books one of the most intellectually exciting historiographical experiences. I agree.
我读那本关于科尔特斯和莫克特祖马会面的书大概是几年前。我想是2018年或19年左右出版的。差不多是那样，是的。它与第一次读帕特里夏·克罗纳（Patricia Croner）的《伊斯兰教起源》或格雷戈里·佩格（Gregory Pegg）的《卡特里派》一样令人兴奋。它是那种完全重塑你对一个你以为自己一直理解的故事的理解的书。令人难以置信的激动人心的书。它说，我认为他对科尔特斯有点苛刻，也许。
I read the one on the meeting between Cortez and Moctezuma maybe a few years ago. It came out in 2018, I think, or 19 or something like that. Something like that, yeah. And it was up there with the excitement of reading Patricia Croner on The Origins of Islam for the first time, or Gregory Pegg on The Cathars. It was kind of one of those books that completely rewires your understanding of a story that you thought that you had always understood. Incredibly thrilling book. Which said, I think he is slightly harsh on Cortes, perhaps.
他讨厌科尔特斯。他绝对鄙视科尔特斯。但他非常、非常强烈地提出了你提到的这一点。科尔特斯需要西班牙国王相信这个故事，否则他，科尔特斯，就犯了罪。他违背了命令，并暴露了自己是一个贪婪的家伙，试图窃取别人的土地。他需要告诉西班牙国王，不，不，不，那是您的土地，我正在努力为您收复它们。所以他需要讲那个故事。但正如你所说，这并不意味着他本人不一定相信它。我认为记住这一点非常重要，即西班牙人在到达诺斯特拉德兰（Nostradland）时完全迷失了方向。
He hates Cortes. He absolutely despises Cortes. But he makes this point very, very strongly that you alluded to. Cortes needs the Spanish king to believe this story because otherwise he, Cortes, has committed a crime. He has gone against his orders and he's revealed himself to be a greedy so-and-so who's trying to steal somebody else's lands. He needs to tell the Spanish king, no, no, no, they're your lands and I'm trying to recover them for you. So he needs to tell that story king, no, no, no, they're your lands and I'm trying to recover them for you. So he needs to tell that story. But as you say, that doesn't mean that he doesn't necessarily come to believe it himself. And I think it's really important to remember that the Spanish are utterly disorientated when they arrive into Nostradland.
他们被奇怪的建筑、奇怪的食物所包围，一切都是新的，这些戴着羽毛的疯狂人说着他们听不懂的语言，他们筋疲力尽，他们害怕，他们正在努力理解一切，当蒙特祖马站起来说这是您的家，我拥有的一切都是您的，这是标准的纳瓦特尔语欢迎和好客的公式。他们抓住了它。马林切正在翻译它们。当然，谁知道她是否值得信任。旋转它。
They're surrounded by weird architecture, weird food, everything new, these crazy people in feathers who are speaking a language they don't understand they're knackered they're frightened they are struggling to make sense of everything and when montezuma stands up and is saying this is your home everything i have is yours which are standard kind of narwhal formulas of welcome and hospitality. They grasp after it. And Malinche is translating them. And of course, who knows whether she can be trusted. Spitting it.
是否她在旋转它。我的意思是，事实当然是，我们永远不会知道这是怎么回事。我认为莫克特祖马的正式语言还有一个方面，即当他在人民面前公开讲话时，他似乎暗示西班牙人是他祖先失散已久的亲戚。你可以绝对看出他为什么要这样做，因为他不想向他的臣民传达他不知道发生了什么。我的意思是，他想暗示，是的，他们看起来很奇怪，但这是我理解的世界的一部分，并声称与他们有某种亲属关系。但再次，你可以看出这将如何
Whether she's spinning it. I mean, the truth is, of course, we'll never know how this goes. I think there's one further aspect of the formal language of Moctezuma is that he seems to imply when he speaks publicly before his people that the Spanish are long lost relatives of his forebears. And you can absolutely see why he would be doing that because he doesn't want to convey to his subjects that he has no idea what's going on. I mean, he wants to imply that, yeah, they look strange, but these are part of the world that I understand and claiming some kind of sense of kinship with them. But again, you could see how that would
提供一些西班牙人随后可以利用的东西。是的，绝对。所以我认为从蒙特祖马的角度来看，他显然没有投降他的王国。我的意思是，那显然是疯狂和荒谬的。他以非常华丽的措辞迎接了他们。他给了他们所有的食物，然后他基本上我想对他们说，现在好好休息吧，我们早上再谈，天知道他把所有的特拉斯卡拉人放在哪里，他们可能被安置在走廊、马厩里，谁知道呢，他们安置了西班牙马、狗，所有这些东西，他们一定为大炮或他们的装备找到了空间，你看，我认为关于他们如何处理特拉斯卡拉人的问题，据我所知，
provide something that the Spanish could then subsequently exploit. Yeah, absolutely. So I think from Montejuma's point of view, he clearly hasn't surrendered his kingdom. I mean, that's obviously mad and nonsensical. He has greeted them in very flowery terms. He's given them all this food and then he basically i think says to them have a good rest now we'll speak in the morning god knows where he's put all the tlachcalans they're probably quartered in corridors stables who knows they've put up the spanish horses the dogs all of that stuff they must have found space for the cannons or their kit you see i think the question of what they've done with the Tlaxcalans, as far as I know,
没有得到回答。不，没人知道。这是叙事中一个非常明显的空白。因为西班牙人也不想让你注意到特拉斯卡拉人。不。因为在他们自己的故事版本中，他们是赢得这场战争的英雄，面对压倒性的困难。如果他们说实话，那就是有时他们
doesn't get answered. No, no one knows. It's a really obvious gap in the narrative. Because also the Spanish don't want you to notice the Tlaxcalans. No. Because in their own version of the story, they are the heroes who have won this war against overwhelming odds. And if they tell the truth, which is sometimes they
进行的战斗中，他们的人数不到自己军队的十分之一，而且他们被为另一个事业而战的本土战士所包围，他们的整个事业看起来就不那么英勇、不那么迷人、不那么令人兴奋了。确实。关于蒙特祖马如何对待特拉斯卡拉人，也就是他人民的敌人，我的意思是，这对他是政治头痛。巨大的。据我所知，我们根本不知道他怎么处理他们。所以已知的未知数，多米尼克。我认为理解这一点的最好方法实际上就是诚实地面对它，并说，我们不知道，我们不知道是因为他们不知道。因为他们中没有人真正知道发生了什么。但我们也不知道，因为各方利益相关者掩盖
fought battles in which they were less than a tenth of their own army, and they were surrounded by native warriors who were fighting for another cause, their whole enterprise looks somehow less heroic, less glamorous, less exciting. It does. The question of how Moctezuma is treating the Tlaxcalans, who are his people's enemies, I mean, that's a political headache for him. Massive. And as far as I know, we have no idea what he's doing with them at all. So known unknowns, Dominic. I think the best way of making sense of this is actually just to be honest about it and to say, we don't know, and we don't know because they don't know. Because none of them really have any sense what's going on. But also we don't know because it's in the interests of everybody on all sides to cover
某些事情符合他们的利益。是的。在事情上蒙上面纱。当然，我们真的不知道莫克特祖马发生了什么，因为正如事件将显示的那样，我们将在下一集中讨论，事情对他来说变得非常糟糕。是的。所以我认为我们应该在这一点上结束第三集。西班牙人在特诺奇蒂特兰（Tenochtitlan）的心脏地带。他们被安置在其中一个
up certain things. Yeah. To draw veils over things. And of course, we don't really know what's going on with Moctezuma because as events will show and that we'll get onto in the next episode, things go horribly wrong for him. Yeah. So I think that we should stop episode three at this point. The Spanish are in the heart of Tenochtitlan. They have been put up in one of
皇家宫殿里。他们在一个湖中心、距离海岸数百英里、距离西班牙数千英里的巨大首都中间，被说着他们听不懂语言的人包围。太可怕了。他们必须问自己的问题是，他们的地位是什么？他们是客人吗？他们是囚犯吗？谁知道呢。这就是马修·雷斯特尔的精彩理论，我们可能会在下一集中讨论。他们是即将进入动物园的生物吗？是的。那是一个多么悬念的结尾啊。所以下一集，会有关于动物园的讨论。所以我希望你会喜欢，因为下一集绝对精彩。当你认为这一集很精彩，而这一集也很精彩时，多米尼克，你太棒了。
the royal palaces. They're in the middle of a vast capital in the heart of a lake, hundreds of miles from the coast, thousands of miles from Spain, surrounded by people who don't speak their language. Terrifying. And the question that they must be asking themselves is, what is their status? Are they guests? Are they prisoners? Who knows? And this is Matthew Restle's brilliant theory, which we'll maybe talk about in the next episode. Are they creatures about to go into a zoo? Yes. What a cliffhanger that is. So the next episode, there will be zoo-related discussion. So I hope you'll enjoy that because the next episode is an absolute banger. When you think this has been a banger, and this has been a banger, Dominic, you've been brilliant.
下一集，更精彩。所以我们会在预定发布时见到你。当然，如果你想现在就继续听，你可以通过加入“其余历史俱乐部”（Restless History Club）来做到这一点。所以我们很快就会见到你。再见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
The next one, even more of a banger. So we will see you when it's scheduled to come out. But of course, if you want to just carry on and listen to it right now, you can do so by joining the Restless History Club. So we will see you very soon. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde.
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《其余是娱乐》（The Rest is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, a splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
那是 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击逐字稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。